wouldn't AK ordinary workday at the
hospital Lowe and Ali is an anesthetist
he's here to check in on his patient
there's a problem with the catheter
along with anesthesia it's also Ali's
job to prepare the patient for surgery
and inform him of all the risks involved
when someone does his job and does it
well it doesn't matter where he's from
or what color is skinny's what about the
communication it's great now and Ali is
a doctor originally from Syria he's one
of many foreign doctors here at the
hospital in Hoyas Vader nearly half the
doctors here aren't German citizens I
came to Germany a year and eight months
ago at first it was hard to communicate
with patients and my colleagues but it's
getting easier at the end when they
don't understand they asked Lauren Ali
comes from the Kurdish region of Syria
he fled the war there and came to
Germany with his family back home he
lived in a leper a city of over two
million now he's in small town boy is
verda when he arrived here he knew
nothing about the town's history at
first I didn't know anything nobody
talked about it I had no problem my
works going well everything's fine with
my neighbors it's all great no problem
so I didn't realize and when you read
about it what did you think then well
that was 20 years ago the people who did
that or probably gone by now
yeah alley boy is better the town that
made headlines during a wave of attacks
against foreigners back in 1991 a mob of
right-wing radicals laid siege to
hostels used by asylum seekers and
contract workers from other countries
right-wing radicals are still a strong
presence in the region the far-right
National Democratic Party holds seats in
the City Council there still aren't that
many foreigners here only around 1% of
the population andreas Crowley man knows
about Hoyas fetters reputation as the
hospital's managing director he recruits
doctors in other countries there he
praises the town's educational and
leisure offerings he has to because
there's a desperate shortage of doctors
in rural Saxony certain be yeah if we
didn't have foreign doctors here this
hospital wouldn't be able to offer
highly specialized care and we couldn't
maintain our inpatient clinic the
hospital does everything to support its
foreign doctors Lau and Ali probably
wouldn't be here if the head of
anesthesia hadn't stepped in personally
for doctors from Syria becoming licensed
to work in Germany is complicated and
presents many hurdles as much meeting we
divorce a lot getting his qualifications
recognised and getting a medical license
wasn't easy it took a long time in the
end he didn't start working here until
August 6 2012 but I kept his post open
for him because he deserved that
opportunity : was full of this whole
scheme and law and Ali has made the best
of that opportunity he's happy with his
work here at the hospital and with the
life in Hoyas vada he doesn't know yet
how long he'll stay though I don't know
what the future is going to bring maybe
a big city maybe I'll stay here I don't
know yet
HT get plan happen
Popoy is better though the town relies
on doctors like Lau and Ali